but first our top story this hour it's
cherished it's a cherished tradition of
the royal family while his actual
birthday falls in November today King
Charles will celebrate his birthday
publicly with the annual birthday parade
for the British sovereign known as
trooping the color it's this it's the
such celebration of the new Monarch's
Reign MTS tie up has more on the
centuries-old ceremony
Lady Elizabeth was to take this it was
1952 when a young Queen Elizabeth II
seen here mounted on Horseback led her
first trooping a color
and now 260 year old tradition that
marks the official birthday of a
reigning monarch a technical head of the
British Armed Forces 2022 the late
Queen's Platinum Jubilee was one of the
largest in recent memory and would be
the last time she would inspect the
hundreds of horses and soldiers as they
perform Battlefield drills to military
music
an annual Hallmark of Britain's hard
power and soft with senior members of
the royal family gather together on the
balcony at Buckingham Palace for what's
known as the fly past this year will yet
again see a few notable absences
trooping the color doesn't always go
smoothly
[Applause]
in 1981 the queen was shot at from a
distance the queen was in the uniform
that didn't stop her from riding on
Horseback at the event for a further
five years only opting to ride in a
carriage instead after her beloved horse
Burmese a gift from the Royal Canadian
Mounted Police retired in preparations
for Charles's first trooping the color
as king marking his 75th birthday the
unusually high temperatures during the
final rehearsal saw at least three
Guardsmen dressed in their heavy tunics
and Bearskin hats fainting from the Heat
but today's weather has cooperated as
King Charles a skilled Horsemen and
former competitive Polo player brought
back the tradition of a reigning monarch
joining the parade in his honor on
Horseback flanked by the Royal Colonels
his son Prince William sister Princess
Anne and youngest brother Prince Edward
a poignant first trooping for someone
other than Queen Elizabeth II in seven
decades for CBS Saturday morning in
Fiesta London
[Music]